so uh one of the things that
will often happen when there
is uh what we would call sort of like a
um saturation coverage story where
with the verdicts yesterday in the derek
chovin case
basically every news channel was
covering it live
right wing media essentially has no
choice but to cover it there's lots of
stories that right-wing media will just
ignore
but when you have like a saturation
story typically right-wing media has to
cover
it and often that leads to completely
unhinged meltdowns and lots of really
funny things so let's go through a few
things that happened yesterday in the
hours following
the three guilty verdicts uh for derek
chauvin in the killing of george floyd
here is greg gutfeld i guess now he's a
comedy host
i guess he's a comedian i don't know he
has a comedy show now on fox news
he seemed to almost completely become
unglued
when a fox news guest called out gutfeld
for his comments on the verdict take a
look at this
now i gotta tell you i heard uh greg a
few minutes ago and i got to tell you i
don't know greg
uh is off his meds if he believes excuse
me
excuse me
if you do not believe that there was
evidence
to support these charges i got a bridge
in brooklyn to scare you
isn't that something just everybody
losing their minds yesterday on
right-wing media
here is a daily wire host saying and
it's just so weird because
these are supposedly the due process and
law and order people here's a daily wire
host
saying the only verdict we could have
trusted would be not guilty
um anything else is not trustworthy what
take a look hours after the judge in the
case
reprimanded maxine waters who flew from
dc
to the city before the jury had started
deliberating to demand
a certain a guilty verdict in fact she
demanded a verdict on premeditated
murder which he wasn't even charged with
and first of all that whole maxine water
is going to to
minneapolis what else could that be
other than an attempt to intimidate and
tamper with the jury what what other
motivation could you have
to fly as a high-ranking politician to
the city where this local murder trial
is happening
and demand that the jury come to a
verdict either you believe in fair
trials
or you don't either you want the the
jury to weigh the evidence and come to a
decision or you don't it's clear that
they don't here the problem
the irony is that the only verdict we
could really trust
is an acquittal in all accounts i think
that would have been the right verdict
but
it's also the only one you can trust
because it's the only one that couldn't
have been motivated by anything
but a look at the evidence
he says a look at the evidence could
only lead to not guilty
by this is like a no true scotsman
fallacy
guilt by definition according to this
guy means the jury did not look at the
evidence what happened to these people
what happened to due process and
respecting the process we have for
jury selection and a judge deciding what
evidence is admissible and is not
what happened um it's almost like they
really never believed it they just would
would go with it if it helped them this
next one's really good is ben shapiro
ben shapiro after the verdict says by
the way is there any evidence that this
was a racial killing and of course what
does that have to do with the charges
it has nothing to do with the charges
take a look both of those speeches were
about
how america is racist again
where is the racial component where is
that that's enough where is it like
has anyone yet provided the shred of
evidence to suggest that it was racial
killing
i wasn't even you know why and then not
only that you have joe biden out there
saying
that america's police all of our systems
are actually systemically racist
the guilty verdicts are for charges that
do not mention
race they were based on the facts of
the case here's one more candace owens
clip
we looked at her appearance with tucker
earlier here's candace owens hanging out
with the daily wire
guys pointing out that really
this is about george floyd being a drug
addict
take a look at this this is literal he's
a drug addict
okay he was a drug addict he abused
women he abused men he
you know this is this is disgusting that
that is it actually grosses me out
do we have no better examples to put
forward in the black community when you
think of the word justice
you think of george floyd i mean how far
we have fallen since martin luther king
just grasping at straws they have no
idea what to do with themselves
going now from fox news and daily wire
to newsmax here is a news max host
saying that the jury sacrificed
derek chovin to the mob yeah no
it's it's pressure on the scale right i
mean this they say justice is blind i
don't think
it was blind in this case at all i think
you had political pressure i think you
had pressure from all these
activist groups going into all this and
i think at the end of the day
people say you know what if we acquit
this guy this city is going to burn
to the ground it is going to burn to the
ground so you had a jury that said you
know what
we're going to have to sacrifice this
guy to the mob and that's exactly what i
think happened today
this was not according to this newsmax
host jurors
looking at the evidence and deciding
guilty or not guilty
it was jurors sacrificing derek shovin
to the mob immediately after
the guilty verdict newsmax host also
saying it was not a fair trial what what
happens tonight we don't know i mean
obviously right now it's still light
outside there's a lot of security around
there you've got
a group of people i i would assume
that's some members of uh
the family of floyd but friends of floyd
they're celebrating
we don't know what this turns into it's
nightfalls again
sometimes there's no appeasing a mob in
a situation like that we don't we have
three
guilty counts the first thing that i
thought of in my head was
you know and we talked a lot about this
with uh with dershowitz uh alan
dershowitz
uh how on earth uh was he expecting to
get a fair trial in this thing there was
a tremendous amount of pressure
on that jury i mean you would have had
to have been out of your mind
to vote to acquit this man knowing full
well that everybody is going to figure
out who you are
and you're going to have the likes of
blm antifa protesters coming after you
with everything they got if you're the
one person that says oh no
i i think he was innocent i think george
floyd probably ate a pocket full of
drugs when the cops came up to him he
had a bad heart they put him on the
ground
if he hadn't done those things he might
have had a stiff neck the next day but
he died instead
i like how it's totally peaceful but he
still has to say well you know
it's light out right now it'll probably
get really dangerous when it's dark out
and of course it didn't and of course
the things that the host is proposing
were debunked in the trial by medical
experts so
yes it's pathetic and um it is
unfortunate that so many people are
already repeating these lines
with absolutely no critical thinking
applied whatsoever
and there is one more that i'm going to
play for you
after the break because it actually
deserves its own segment it is tucker
carlson
appearing to have a psychotic break and
kicking his guest off air when talking
about the verdict so
right after this short break we'll jump
into that and we will have more of these
clips
on our instagram page you can find us on
instagram
at david pakman show one of our sponsors
is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on you can
often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman